bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission qui peut être considéré comme
essentiel puisque le gouvernement ne l'a
pas encore interdite
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler des secteurs justement essentiel
pas essentiel et de leurs de l'impact du
coronavirus sur les gaffard bonjour
estelle bonjour olivier bonjour à tous
bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode de ses
caches depuis le 29 octobre dernier et
1re confinement en national les
commerces neuner essentielle ont tiré
leur rideau de fer confrontée à la
grogne à des commerçants les grandes
surfaces elles ont dû fermer leurs
rayons à de produits hanon essentiel
alors face à ces restrictions les sites
de e-commerce comme amazon ensemble
tirer leur épingle du jeu les gars fac
comme on les appelle sont ils les grands
gagnants de la crise du coc vite 19 la
crise sanitaire va t-elle à long terme a
bouleversé nos modes de consommation
on va en parler à dans cette émission et
pour cela on fera en deuxième partie
avec virginie mon voisin enseignante
chercheuse en économie à grenoble et
vice-présidente de l'adec l'association
pour le développement des études
keynésienne amazon le mastodonte du
commerce en ligne est de plus en plus à
critiquer toute l'année son activité n a
cessé de croître
à la faveur de la crise sanitaire les
commerçants contrainte de fermer eux
sont ulcérés et le gouvernement essaye
tant bien que mal de chercher à des
solutions vous voyez le tiroir cash
d'antoine bassesse
ah sacré micmac second confinement on
ferme les commerces jugés non essentiels
par le gouvernement mais pas les grandes
surfaces puis on se rend compte que dans
les grandes surfaces il y à des produits
l'un essentiel joué à dix livres cd dvd
et bien d'autres du coup on les empêche
finalement de vendre les produits en
question
dernier épisode en date la grande
distribution doit aussi renoncer aux as
cannes collecte c'est à dire les
commandes effectuées sur ces articles
dont les rayons sont donc déjà interdit
au libre service
on passera sur la communication du
gouvernement un peu bancal ce n'est pas
notre genre d' être médisant d'un autre
côté il y en a un qui se frotte les
mains c'est jeff bezos ce qui doit être
le seul à qui fait son ad 2020 sur le
3ème trimestre amazon a vu son chiffre
d'affaires augmenter de 37% son bénéfice
triplé dépassant les six milliards de
dollars et prévoit entre 112 et 114
milliards de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires pour le quatrième trimestre
généralement le meilleur de l'année
grâce aux fêtes de noël
le groupe aurait carrément recruté près
de 400000 personnes dans le monde depuis
le début de l'année bref les affaires
vont plutôt bon train alors pour freiner
les ardeurs d'amazon le gouvernement
leur a demandé de supprimer leur
campagne de pub massive sur le pré black
friday
l'opération commerciale d'avant noël à
la fin du mois de novembre
ce qu'ils ont accepté de faire sans
toutefois pour le moment supprimer le
black friday en lui même faut pas
déconner non plus
on y vient de le voir ces chiffres
faramineux d'amazon est ce qu'on
pourrait traduire cela comme un pas de
plus vers la digitalisation de
l'économie certainement m'enfin faut pas
rendre amazon responsable de sa majo ni
il bénéficie de de la gestion qu'on a
fait de la de la crise sanitaire
il est là il travaillait avant et donc
il n'a pas changé de modèle pour la
crise sanitaire
simplement quand quand on interdit tous
les commerces de fonctionner faut pas
s'étonner que les gens se tournent vers
amazon donc c'est au gouvernement de
gérer un petit peu mieux les choses
c'est pas à amazon de se battre la
coulpe pour le chiffre d'affaires qu'il
fait si vous n'interdisez pas les autres
les autres magasins de fonctionner vous
verrez que amazon fera moins de fra - de
business donc voilà enfin il faut quand
même se rendre compte que par exemple
aux états unis si mes souvenirs sont
bons le les ventes au détail sur
internet représentait 7 à 8% du marché
des ventes globales donc il faut arrêter
aussi de penser que les amazones et
absolument tout puissant alors
maintenant c'est ça fait partie des
gaffes à les gaffes à ont depuis des
années gagner énormément d'argent et
aujourd'hui sont devenus plus puissante
que la plupart des états c'est un
problème c'est un problème sur lequel il
faut réfléchir quand des entreprises
deviennent plus puissante que des états
ça pose un souci sur la démocratie
mais sinon on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
sans arrêt chercher un coupable
le coupable aujourd'hui c'est les gens
qui gèrent la crise c'est pas c'est pas
amazon qui en profitent c'est pas
facebook qui en profite
il en profite parce qu'ils sont là et
que c'est mal géré olivier rapidement
avant de passer à la deuxième partie est
ce que dans cette digitalisation on
pourrait aussi voir et ce qu'il peut y
avoir une opportunité de voir par
exemple émerger de nouveaux acteurs
français qui pourrait venir concurrencer
le géant américain
ça c'est ce qu'on attend toujours à
chaque fois qu'il se passe quelque chose
on se dira la france va en bénéficier et
puis quelques mois plus tard on dit ah
bah finalement la france n'a pas
bénéficié bon si si on crée un petit peu
des conditions plus intéressantes
peut-être que l'on verrait l'émergence
de grands groupes en france mais ça
n'est pas le cas et ça sera pas
forcément le cas et ça ne sera
probablement pas le cas cette fois ci
encore merci à lilian passe tout de
suite à la deuxième partie de cette
émission
et on continue de parler d' amazon
dégâts fahey de la crise sanitaire et
pour cela nous sommes en liaison avec
virginie mon voisin bonjour vous êtes
enseignante chercheuse en économie à
grenoble et vice-présidente de l'adec
l'association pour le développement des
études keynésienne merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci
de me recevoir
alors on l'a vu en depuis le continent
en france amazon est sous le feu des
critiques accusée notamment de
concurrence est déloyale le dg france de
la fille en lui évoque chez nos
confrères de rtl des critiques basées
sur des informations non vérifiées il a
aussi précisé que son entreprise
représente aujourd'hui 1 % du commerce
français on n'est absolument pas un
acteur dominant at il dit le cabinet
kantar quant à lui estime qu amazon
représente 22% du marché du e-commerce
en france alors virginie mon voisin
faut-il jeter à la pierre à amazon est
ce que les choses iraient here est elle
mieux si amazon il n'existait pas amazon
exister il n'existerait pas ce serait
quelqu'un doute qui existeraient et
c'est à dire que c'est comme ça a été
dit juste avant finalement est ce qu'on
peut vraiment vouloir amazon d'être là
où il y en ait dans la mesure de toute
façon sur sur tout ce qui est réseau
internet et c'est naturellement les
économistes savent que les monopoles
apparaissent grâce appelle les
externalités de réseau c'est à dire que
plus vous êtes connue et la plus on a
envie d'être sur ce réseau là parce
qu'il ya eu même d'un parce que votre
voisin ou vos amis utilisent le même
réseau et donc c'est comme microsoft
microsoft et qui fait partie des gaffes
à main pour qu'on utilise tous microsoft
est ce que windows est vraiment
supérieure à d'autres systèmes
les spécialistes on nous dira pas
forcément mais moins de gras mais comme
on utilise tous microsoft c'est quand
même plus pratique
amazon c'est pareil amazon c'est pareil
reconnaît nos amis connaissent ont
habitués donc si c'était pas ma zone ce
sera un autre et il serait aussi en
position dominante
je voudrais vous faire réagir à cet
édito a paru dans les échos le 11
en novembre dernier il faut reconnaître
que si nos petits commerces ouvrent
c'est surtout à cause de l'essor des
hypermarchés ou des chaînes spécialisées
c'est parce que nos centres villes qui
n'aime plus la voiture repousse les
blancs loser c'est parce que notre état
qui se nourrit de taxes et d'impôts ne
cesse de ponctionner toutes les
activités économiques préférant prélever
plus que de réduire ses propres coûts on
ne sauverait pas nos commerçants en
interdisant demain amazon de prendre des
commandes quand les boutiques sont
fermées il faut punir amazon quand il
enfreint la loi
pas quand il ne fait que son métier
virginie mon voisin vous êtes d'accord
avec alors c'est vrai qu'ils redoublent
ya un double mouvement là il ya un
double mouvement c'est demain d'un côté
et l'apparition de ces géants sur sur
internet et est ce que vous disiez juste
avant amazon qui dit qu'il est en
position dominante
soyons très clairs aux états unis 75 %
des livres sont vendus par amazon sur
manette wii sont position ils sont en
position dominante mais dont il ya ce
mouvement la sueur sur le e-commerce et
d'un autre côté ce qui est ce qui
apparaît dans cet édito des échos et que
on connaît bien malheureusement et c'est
un mouvement qui s'amplifie
ce sont les centres villes qui se vident
de leur substance alors est ce que c'est
parce que on interdit la voiture en
centre-ville est ce que les loyers aussi
son deuxième très cher en centre ville
c'est compliqué pour les petits
commerces en tous cas pour les villes
moyennes pour les villes moyennes
il ya ce mouvement de désertification
des centre-villes de la part du commerce
avec en contrepoint l'apparition de ceux
de ce métier manager de centre-ville je
suis pas entendu parler il ya certaines
là certaines petites villes aux villes
moyennes qui qui dédie un poste au sein
des municipalités pour revitaliser le
tissu commercial la vie ou la vie tout
simplement il ya jean ouvrir un commerce
en face en face d'une crèche ou en face
d'un centre de loisirs ça peut se
concevoir comme ça et donc ce double
mouvement d'un côté internet qui compte
depuis
en plus de place dans nos vies et d'un
autre côté ces centres livre qui se
dévitalise quelques on arrive à cette
situation est explosive
pendant confinement qui accélère le
mouvement qui est présent depuis depuis
5 6 ans olivia votre avis sur cette
analyse on va sur le l'article des échos
je suis totalement en phase et puis file
je le redis encore une fois la gestion
de la crise sanitaire vous fermez pas
les librairies
vous allez avoir des gens qui vont aller
dans des librairies
si vous voulez faire mais évidemment ils
vont se tourner sur un autre moyen pour
obtenir le lit qui vole donc tout ça c c
si vous n'avez pas ces restrictions si
vous n'avez pas ces fermetures de petits
commerces et bien les gens ne se
tourneront pas forcément vers amazon en
plus faible c'est quelque chose que vous
pouvez faire individuellement au lieu de
râler et au lieu de critiquer et au lieu
de dire le responsable c'est amazon est
banale et pas sur amazon
commandez votre bouquin chez votre
libraire vous n'êtes pas obligé d'y
aller
vous n'êtes pas obligé d'aller sur
facebook non plus que je sache donc vous
êtes libres et si vous avez envie au
lieu d'aller demander l'interdiction au
gouvernement faites le vous même vous
n'êtes pas obligés de consommer du
facebook vous n'êtes pas obligé de alors
il y en a d'autres en effet où je suis
parfaitement d'accord malheureusement
vous êtes obligés d'utiliser microsoft
parce que tout le monde utilisent
microsoft où vous êtes obligé
de d'utiliser apple parce que apple a
verrouillé tout le système est donc vous
êtes obligé de le faire mais il y a des
choses sur lequel vous n'êtes absolument
pas contraint par personne à le faire si
vous n'avez pas envie je vous dis
d'aller sur facebook vous n'allez pas
sur facebook et puis le problème est
réglé
donc il faut aussi se prendre un tout
petit peu en main serait mieux plutôt
que de porter des accusations
systématiques sur sur des groupes qui
qui font qu'ils font leur boulot enfin
je veux dire
amazon il sait pas lui qui a créé le coc
vite que je sache donc mais c'est lui
qui bénéficie de la gestion qu'on en a
fait mais c'est tout au delà de la crise
sanitaire est ce que cette ce succès est
des gaffes à peuvent aussi être imputé à
comme le disait à bien gêné mon voisin à
la désertion à la désertification des
centre-villes ou alors comme le précise
s'était dit oh au fait que et bien
l'état
taxer et ponctionne aussi les activités
économiques
mais finalement la crise le centre ville
on sait très bien qu'ils aient déserté
alors par la gestion qu'on en fait par
les prix les prix de l'immobilier par
tout un tas de choses qui fait que les
gens de ce s'évade à la campagne et le
co vide a renforcé sa aussi près préfère
être confiné au milieu des vaches plutôt
qu'au milieu de la pollution et des
voitures et donc vous avez ce mouvement
là qui fait que tous les tous les tous
les commerces dans le centre
se ferment les uns après les autres mais
vous avez ce mouvement là depuis des
années
depuis des années avec les supermarchés
qui sont en général en périphérie des
villes
vous avez des fermetures dans le centre
d'aidé petits commerces c'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau et c'est pas
quelque chose qui est arrivé à cause du
coup vite ça fait longtemps que ça se ça
dure et ça fait longtemps que ça se
développe on va marquer une courte pause
rien dans un instant bienvenue à danser
cash si vous nous rejoignez les cas face
on tient là les gagnants de la crise
sanitaire c'est le thème de cette
émission et pour cela nous sommes en
liaison avec virginie vos voisins
enseignante chercheuse en économie à
grenoble alors du côté des emplois
amazon se défend d'avoir créé quatre
cent mille emplois dans le monde en
france 130 mille emplois sont liés à la
firme dont neuf manque 300 emplois
directs selon as le dg frédéric duval
virginie mon voisin amazon contribuer
d'une certaine façon de façon positive à
l'économie française
oui alors effectivement présenté les
chiffres de l'emploi dit comme ça
forcément sais je sais bien mais bon on
connaît tous les questionnements qu'il
ya autour d'eux des conditions de
travail chez amazon
c'est quand même un peu compliqué et
puis comment mettre en balance mettre en
balance un géant comme cela qu'ils m'ont
n'a pas encore parlé j'ai vu quand même
quelques éléments apparaître mais sur la
question d'optimisation fiscale soit à
dire qu'on a quand même une entreprise
qui paye qui joue à fond sur
l'optimisation fiscale on va dire les
choses de façon neutre et donc sa
contribution à l'économie française par
rapport à ce qu'elles pourraient être et
par amen ou quoique là
réellement n'est pas à la hauteur c'est
à dire que certes il ya eu une fois mais
au niveau des contributions au nez au
niveau de l'impact social sociétal et
les combats
olivier a justement un mot sur la taxe
gafsa qui devrait être appliqué en
france en décembre l'êta a de dhr est
prélevé 3% du chiffre d'affaires réalisé
en france par une trentaine
d'entreprises du numérique
il faudrait les prélever plus ses gaffes
ah oui mais le problème c'est que vous
il faut pas s'imaginer que aujourd'hui
une phase le poids il va y avoir un
chantage à l'emploi très clair amazon va
nous dire où d'accord vous voulez nous
taxer on on part du pays
donc le aujourd'hui on sait on sait très
bien que ça va être très compliqué
d'appliquer une taxe gaf a
ad à des géants comme ça qu'ils vont
trouver le moyen de finalement de passer
au travers et c'est pas monsieur le
maire qui va nous concocter quelque
chose qui tout seul avec ses petits bras
qui va nous concocter quelque chose qui
sera qui permettra de récupérer de
l'argent sur les sur les gaffes a donc
n'imaginais pas que tout d'un coup nos
énarques soit devenu brillant l'aumône
dans la nuit le coc vite ça fait s'agit
pas sur le cerveau donc malheureusement
ça ne veut ça n'en fera pas des gens
compétents donc voilà non vous n'aurez
pas aujourd'hui bien sûr qu' il faudrait
mais pour cela il faudrait qu'ils aient
réellement des pays qu'ils soient
souverains et qui ne soit pas diluer
dans une europe où vous aurez toujours
un pays qui va refuser toujours un pays
qui va dire ben non oui mais non moi
j'ai obtenu des conditions intéressantes
donc je vais pas voter et je vous
rappelle qu'il faut l'unanimité pour
tous donc vous n'aurez pas de taxes
européennes
donc monsieur le maire va bricoler une
petite taxe comme ça pour dire qu'il en
a fait une et vous n'aurez pas au final
le les retombées que ils peuvent espérer
gêner mon voisin comment peut-on à tirer
profit de la réussite de ces entreprises
où ça me paraît vraiment difficile
ça me parait moments difficiles et en
fait la difficulté à la fois de taxer de
taxer ces géants du numérique mais pas
que il ya d'autres entretiens il
yad'autres géante où il est difficile
d'appliquer une fiscalité plus juste ou
en pick à la hauteur de leur chiffre
d'affaires donc dans l'ensemble
en général c'est compliqué en plus sur
ces entreprises du numérique ce qui est
là où je nuancerais un petit peu ce qui
vient d'être dit y'a pas que rome qui a
du mal
les etats-unis ont du mal aussi à
légiférer être performante par rapport
aux problèmes posés par les gars femme
ne serait-ce on parle de monopole tout à
l'heure les états unis ont des lois
depuis longtemps depuis la fin du 19e
siècle antitrust sherman act est bon
donc tout ça normalement être très
encadré et il n'arrive à empêcher les
modèles il n'arrive pas à avoir une
législation et une action performance
vis-à-vis de ces grandes entreprises
donc effectivement nous les européens
tous les français les etats-unis n'ont
qu donc fait c'est un combat sans issue
et concrètement alors sans issue a oui
et non parce que j'ai un jeu j'en veux
me lancer un petit peu et puis d'être à
la fois optimiste et pessimiste pour
l'avenir c'est à dire que le danger
venir pour eux et la part de les
entreprises chinoises
parce que quand on parle de géants du
net y aller gâcha certes mais il ne faut
pas oublier les géants du net chinois
qui commence à jouer en termes de nombre
d'utilisateurs de tas d'entreprises
on n'est pas loin on commence est pas
loin et donc il va y avoir concurrence
il va y avoir et là ça va réintroduire
un petit peu d'enjeu pour ces
entreprises là et on va parier sur
l'avenir n'est en tout cas de telles que
ça va nous manque c'est un petit peu ce
pouvoir grandissant un convoi la dgac
olivier vous êtes d'accord le danger
vient des entreprises chinoises
alors je sais pas si c'est un danger
mais en effet il vient de
de chine qui équilibrent un petit peu
les choses et puis vous savez il ya
quand même il ya eu quand même quelques
déclarations récentes
ou les le gouvernement trump a
[Musique]
à élever la voix vis-à-vis des dégâts
femme pourquoi parce qu'en fait ils
viennent un peu mégalomane les les
patrons de sega famé et ils l'ouvrent
trop c'est à dire que il commence à se
mêler de choses qui sont plutôt de
l'ordre du gouvernement donc comme ils
sont plus puissants des certains
gouvernements vous les entendez un peu
donner leur avis et essayer d'influencer
ou peser sur la politique américaine
et là vous avez vous avez un risque pour
eux qui est que à un moment ils
ressortent une loi anti trust et qui
cassent une entreprise ou de degas
femmes on les divise en plusieurs
parties pour limiter leur leur poids
c'est une possibilité ça a déjà été fait
dans le passé du temps où les politiques
avaient un petit peu plus de colonne
vertébrale qu'aujourd'hui donc keith
avait tapé du poing sur la table
aujourd'hui
j'ai peur que monsieur by donne est pas
le le point suffisamment lourd sur la
table pour peser vis-à-vis des gars
femmes mais enfin bon on peut aussi
penser à ça quand quand les les patrons
de ces entreprises se mêle de la
politique et vol on l'a vu d'ailleurs
sur la libre à avec la avec facebook
quand ils ont voulu lancer leur propre
monnaie
tout d'un coup ça a fait réagir les
gouvernements et donc ils sont quand
même sous l'oeil des gouvernements qui
veulent les contrôler alors est ce
qu'ils y arriveront ça c'est une autre
affaire mais il ya cette possibilité là
merci beaucoup virginie à mon voisin
d'avoir été parmi nous dans cette
émission je rappelle que vous êtes
enseignant chercheur en économie à
grenoble et vice-présidente de l'adec
l'association pour le développement des
études keynésienne olivier nous on
continue avec les questions cash et
première question a sélectionné cette
semaine en rapport avec notre émission
sur l'euro numérique la question de jean
michel galopin bonjour quid des banques
scandinaves ne serait-elle pas plus
résiliente olivier alors une banque pour
qu'elle soit résiliente
il ya deux il ya deux conditions je
dirais un il faut qu'elle ne faut pas
qu'elles prêtent donc qu'il faut pas
qu'elle soit sur le circuit
interbancaire
et la deuxième chose c'est que il ne
faut pas que l utilise d'effet de levier
et qu'elle est une bande de petits
traders qui s'amuse avec les fonds de la
banque en ayant un multiple quelquefois
et de 40 x 50 x 60 x et donc quoi on
sait très bien que dans ce cas là ça va
se terminer mal
voilà donc je ne sais pas ce qu'il en
est de d'aidé des banques scandinaves
mais si vous avez ces deux conditions
qui sont réunis eh bien elles sont sur
tout autre chose à présent avec à la
question de fred 79 comment
percevez-vous le sursaut de la bourse
suite à l'annoncé du vaccin kaiser et
bien failli leur en grand spécialiste de
l'érection à un provoquer une érection
monumentale de la bourse 8% sur sur
paris et
six ou sept sur l'allemagne etc c'est
évidemment aberrant si vous voulez c'est
à dire que on sait très bien comment ça
se sent ça fonctionne sont des
algorithmes aujourd'hui sont pas des
gérants derrière il ya eu très peu de
volume d'ailleurs sur 7 sur cette
journée là on annonce un vaccin
il ya une page de deux communiqués de
pfizer qui s'attachent bien à mettre son
code isin pour que les gens n'aient pas
trop de mal à le trouver et puissent
acheter l'action des vaccins sassounian
n'aura pas donc il faut arrêter de jouer
là dessus en permanence ça se trouve il
en aura pas et aujourd'hui ils ont fait
une étude qui est à peine sorti avec 94
patients fin c'est ridicule comme si moi
demain je disais à bâtir j'ai le vaccin
olivier delamarche al vaccins et la
bourse 38%
c'est ridicule donc maintenant on sait
comment ça se passe vous avez des
algorithmes qui dès qu'ils entendent le
mot vaccins se précipite sur la bourse
et achète tout parce qu'ils ont été
programmés pour ça et sans avoir la
moindre réflexion parce que il était
évident que ça ne va rien changer
c'est pas pour ça que ce soir on va nous
annoncer que le confinement est finie
c'est pas pour ça que l'activité va
redémarrer et donc c'est juste ridicule
à ce moment là il fallait si on avait
été dans un monde normal quelques
quelques achats sur files heures ce qui
est un col en fait c'est est-ce qu'ils
vont peut-être trouver et le vaccin et
le vendre et à ce moment là il y avait
le titre qui montait de 5 % et s'était
terminée mais ça ne devait pas entraîné
toute la bourse
vous avez eu des des hausses monumentale
sur des types comme air france etc
ah bon pourquoi les les voyages ont
repris non évidemment qu'ils ont pas
repris donc air france est toujours en
faillite oui
air france est toujours en faillite mais
ça a pris 20% et donc c'est ridicule
voilà merci merci beaucoup olivier c'est
la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas que vous
pouvez poser toutes vos questions à
olivier sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag rt cash on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine et on se quitte avec
votre dernier mot olivier et bien au
lieu de chercher un coupable
systématiquement agissons